okay
for people joining this live stream we
are talking about
our long and development
quantum computing functionality that
will be going into
12 2. um
so before we start there it i asked me
to ask you a question which is the first
section which is unrelated
so we just want to see what you think
about these two things
provisionally i'm
i think this could go even a tiny bit
longer
and what do you think about this the
the enlarged the third one feels a bit
heavy
so perhaps a bit smaller yeah i think it
could go like
20 percent smaller or something
but it's got to be distinctly not as a
pure dot
right
okay okay so the agenda is separated
into
uh so at the end we have all the symbols
so there are
18 new symbols and we have a guide page
and a tutorial so these are all things
we could look at
great and there are a couple of global
questions i have there
which is the name we have been doubting
about quantum computing or
just quantum actually we have both names
in different places
and then how to release it whether it's
a built-in packet
or repeating built-in package building
backlit
or something in the particular report
how many
um how many new functions does it have
18 right now how general do we think it
in my is i mean we should all
express our opinions but i think i think
this is more quantum computing
at the moment than than quantum and for
example
quantum discrete state it talks about q
d
and and the terminology is very quantum
computing like i think
yes that's what i think too jonathan
what do you think
i i agree although i mean it's only the
terminology is only quantum computing
like because we kind of
meant it to be that way i mean that the
functionality is general enough that it
can apply to any sort of finite
dimensional quantum system
um it's just a question
right but i mean what would be the
bridge what would be the first kinds of
finite dimensional quantum systems to
which it might apply things in chemistry
for example
i i doubt it um i mean
this is the this is the thing right that
most of the finite dimensional quantum
systems people care about are the ones
in quantum information theory
well in your version of the world
i mean i'm not sure that i'm not sure
that's generally true
i mean i you know i don't really know
what other
um
i don't know michael might have a
comment but my experience has been that
sort of people in quantum chemistry
mostly care about infinite dimensional
cases
i agree yeah i think so too
okay guys the if we're doing guide page
stuff for goodness sake don't have
things that wrap lines
um but unfortunately these are hard to
describe otherwise
right any longer names
okay well let's go to santa what's here
okay
that doesn't seem like an operation
quantum discrete state is not an
operation
right basic objects right basic
operations then comes
um
in fact that they're mostly objects
except things like quantum distance or
quantum partial trace
[Music]
so what are quantum partial
how do those
what is this i mean is this state
manipulation or something what is
quantum partial trace how would you
characterize it
i think this should be called basic
objects
yep and that goes down
quantum measurement operator measurement
outcome
tensor product as far as tensor product
well i mean state operations is that
right
statement state manipulation
except that one can also perform uh
tensor products and things over
operators and measurements it's not it's
not just
it's objects what about the other ones
here uh
those are those except for quantum
distance i believe
they all apply to both the states and
operators
okay so what should we call these
basic operations i think partial partial
trace only works for states
okay all right so but what kind of a
thing is this as compared to
that that's a if if true that's a
limitation
if we can take tens of products of
operators we should be able to take
partial traces of operators
all right can i just get a sense of
what's here okay so
um oh okay and should i be looking also
at the
where's the tutorial where should i look
to try and understand what's going on
so it's in the in the tutorial um
yeah in the tutorials directory there is
a quantum computing
technology
there's a stephen wolfram tutorial what
the heck does that mean
i wonder what that is
uh actually right now the tutorial is
like
mostly applications i haven't
explained like each function yet in the
tutorial
but it needs a bit of introduction but i
think it's
from the point of view quantum computing
looks quite nice
with the main examples in the area and
yeah
okay quantum discrete state so if i take
this as an example just so
to try to understand something um
someone on our live stream is asking
whether this what type of quantum
computer or what type of quantum
computer can this be executed yeah well
that's the life of quantum computing i
don't know that we've looked at any of
this api
stuff i mean as the years go by that
just seems just more and more fictional
but i don't know whether we've looked at
anything there
have we well it's quantum compile
that's a function we have called that i
don't think it has been implemented
yet you guys
it's kind of a joke right because it's
like
that's the thing that to implement that
oh i see i see into into particular
operators for particular kinds of
particular technologies and so on right
right right i mean i don't know what i
don't know if it's advanced in the last
couple of months but i mean
when rookie and i were looking at this
back in whenever it was march
uh we had a sort of prototype working
but it wasn't you know it wasn't cleaned
up and fully implemented
what's his status
can somebody speak to that needs about
like
three more weeks of work i guess
okay and and do we have do we do we know
what the targets are for different
technologies
no no we mostly based it off of the
universal q compile package that was
published i think
okay well it seems like this is an
important thing to have
so i mean is there something for to to
work on
yes probably okay
where is so okay jose what should happen
here
um well this was not planned i mean as
far as i'm concerned this was not
planned for our first release
if if if no it's not necessary it's not
necessary but it's desirable
and since the whole thing's packed
updated well we might as well do that
well that i mean i would like to get
that
clear how we are going to release this
if if we want it
in 12 2 i mean if we have it into
two as part of system that's a bit more
than than what we wanted
no no we're not going to do that it's
right
i mean you know we should have released
this in the paclet form years ago
but we didn't but let's do that now and
i think i think
it should be a package just like you
know
unity link or any of these other things
as a package
that's what i think so if if we have it
as a package
the the the problematic thing with
packages is that every single example
will need
these needs at the beginning
i thought we had a way to deal with that
i thought we had a way to deal with that
in documentation
i don't think so i thought that we had a
way that that in the click to copy that
it automatically included those
i see okay then i would have to well
okay
because the the alternative is also if
we put it in the packet repo
then it can be downloaded from there and
it goes directly as a backlit into
system functionality which would be
nice no that's not a good idea it's not
a good idea and i
i hate that pattern as well i think that
pattern is just gonna
cause people to have these ridiculous
towers of dependencies that is exactly
what we're trying to avoid
i see right i actually think it's a
i mean i actually really don't like
these things these packets that install
into the system how could that possibly
end well
right you either depend on who you don't
if you depend on it
you know then you've got some whole
dependency throat clearing thing you've
got to do at the beginning
it's not good
how ready i mean you know we've been
hashing this
out for multiple years here how ready is
this
to go into system if we decided to put
it there
well it would have to be totally
experimental
sure that's okay
i mean do we think from a design point
of view do we think we fully work this
through
my worry is the future extension to more
general quantum mechanics that's
something that i'm still
not sure this will scale well in that
direction
and and to have something in system it
would be nice if that okay
um michael your comments here like
quantum basis for example
seems a slightly odd thing to me
honestly
i mean we want the basis outside of
crandom
we want the bases for l2 or maybe
rigid hilbert space or whatever
so what's your point a little bit
what rositra said like what is the
connection say to
the hermit polynomials they form bases
yeah
so um one thing that may be worth
mentioning so
at least when we when we first started
designing this it was design these were
designed to be system symbols
um obviously the scope has changed since
then but the reason why we chose to use
phrases like quantum discrete state
quantum discrete operator as opposed to
quantum state quantum operator
was specifically to avoid this you know
the situation of possible collision with
more general quantum mechanics
because then everyone knows that we're
dealing with the you know the discrete
finite dimensional
case um
okay let's look at the different op
possibilities okay
so we think in terms of of um
quality of the development that's here
this could be an experimental system
function yes or no
it's very difficult to decide i think i
think it could
i think it could okay
well then maybe it should be i mean i i
don't think that we're going to
okay jonathan you're when you use this
in the quantum to multi-way system and
so on stuff
yep um what does that look like i mean
so
so what do you mean
well
okay hold on i'm i'm let's let's go on a
little bit
looking at some more details and then
let's loop back to this question i mean
i'm i'm sort of leaning
given your comments about
um
i mean 18 symbols is not that bad
the the okay uh
the first design the first serious
design meeting we had about this last
well uh sorry yeah no last year um
you said something to the effect of
quantum mechanics has been around for a
hundred years maybe we should just bite
the bullet and have a load of quantum
symbols
yeah that i remember saying something
along those lines
right and yes i mean that was i was
going to repeat that actually yeah yeah
right um but my point was that i mean
although we dropped that convention at
least when i was
initially designing things the i felt
like having the discrete
descriptor there was kind of our get out
clause
right and then if we want to have a more
general you know quantum state quantum
operator function that reduces the
quantum discrete state in
in the discrete case then we can do that
well so what do we not have discrete in
we have quantum discrete basis we don't
have quantum discrete basis there
right right um
and i see so again you know a couple
things have been changed so i remember
in the version
i implemented quantum what's now called
quantum measurement operator was called
quantum discrete measurement and things
so it seems that we we've dropped the
conventions a bit
but well but they may be extendable
anyway so
sure yeah in which case we should we
should drop the discrete from state and
operator
no we shouldn't because we don't know if
they're generalizable yet
but why would why would measurements be
generalizable but operators not but you
know
i don't know why did we drop the
discrete
measurement why do we drop the discrete
word there
yeah that wasn't my decision well but
but somebody can speak to it
i'm not sure why that happened we should
put it back though
for sure
well okay so which of these
i mean tensor product is that discrete
well i mean everything is discrete right
so if we really wants to be protected we
should
we should have everything have to you
know
have a discrete descriptor
um
if we did that by the way we can we
could shorten a bunch of these
descriptions we don't have to say
discrete discrete discrete all over the
place
um i mean i do think quantum
discrete evolution would be better than
quantum evolution quantum evolution is a
pretty general concept
right oh i mean same with bases and
everything yeah
all right what do you think jose michael
if we add discrete here and we say
you know quantum discrete everything
here um and put it in system
michael i i haven't looked so much at it
so i cannot give
like like what i see right now like my
first thing would be
what every real life evolution is
and not hamiltonian
that's beyond my reading level explain
like uh real life is not uh
unitary because we have coupling to the
environment
losses yeah right i understand that
although do people really take that into
account
yes really how yes how do they know
enough about the environment to do it
you don't have to that's
that's the main spirit of the krauss
linplat theory
you have you know the theoretical
structure it can have so that it is
positive
what epoch in the development of quantum
mechanics does that come from
1970 72 davis
okay might be after my time in some
sense
i mean but but seriously i mean when
people do
random quantum chemistry things are they
doing that
are they when they're doing quantum
computing are they doing that
i think so really yeah because like they
do it in the lab so
the if they have a iron representation
it couples to to the infrared
field well i know it does but do they
actually account for that i mean
yeah that's the main this is how
otherwise do you get the coherence which
is the deal breaker for
i understand that but i thought they
didn't get the i mean and when people do
standard you know oh let's study this
teleportation protocol
they're not including the coherence
but but this is a different story i feel
like
what's a different story teleportation
okay hold on hold on hold on just
physics moment here
what is the form of this the so this
coupling
leads to we normally have a unitary
operator
that represents the evolution what what
happens in this case
in in your lin glad case what does it
look like does it still a unitary
operator or is it no it's not only
unitary
okay and what is the form of the
correction to the unitary piece
doubly commutators which are called
cross operators
and that communicates with what with
what operators with the density matrix
so normally you have a for neumann like
version of a leadable equation
so dot equal
hro times i and then you get double
commutators with
with operators you know the general form
of
and those operators represent
i mean those operators have certain i
mean it's like an operator product
expansion or something where you're
looking at the first order terms
know this is actually exact you can show
every
every ques like in general you would
include the environment and then you
trace the environment out
and after doing this you know how the
thing must look like
so what does that mean in terms of i
mean so so what's the minimal case of
this i mean i have some random the
minimum case is you have a quantum
particle in air
and it decoheres and then you get such p
comma p
comma o and x comma x
and how quickly there's a decoy here 10
to the minus 20
10 minus 24 seconds what sets that
time scale
the scattering events uh around it
but so something must know something
about that scattering in order to set
that time scale i mean these
communicators must have a scale
the prefectures the expertise
dimensional pre-factors
so what is the so there's some constant
of nature
that is the decoherence time no no it's
not a coincidence
it depends on the environment okay but i
mean
in our okay it's like standard
temperature and pressure standard
decoherence time
is that right no no that's really a
standard it depends on all kinds of
things
well i understand that but okay but but
in what you're saying is
okay what you're saying is that
in this so the point you're making is
the density matrix winds up being some
horribly off-diagonal messy thing in the
beginning
okay and in the end he diagonalizes
i didn't know there was an actual
formalism that did that i'm obviously
out of date
um well hang on michael so very naive
question
um for a given time yeah is it the the
the lindbladian isn't that just a
quantum channel
yes so we can represent it
in this framework
we have okay i was just reading this i
would expect
like in the usage message of quantum
evolution to be
quantum hamiltonian or lingudin right
right so i mean
this is a this is an argument for
introducing a you know in addition to
quantum hamiltonian
one that includes the you know the limb
blood master equation or something
um but that's not out of the scope of
the current framework
as at least as far as i understand it
yes but the code is not there yet there
is nothing at all about quantum channel
okay so that's part of the to-do list
am i going insane didn't we prototype
quantum channel we did but again it
wasn't incorporated into the
main package it's in the same realm as
quantum compile
right but we have code for it i mean we
have code that does something
yeah yeah we do okay so then in
in the workflow who who should work on
that code
ruhi who should work on that code
i can i can work on quantum channel and
quantum compile and put it into the
package
since it was my code initially okay
all right okay
is there a way to get a stub of those
things in there very quickly that could
be subsequently packed updated
at this point i don't think so because
they worked with the
version of the package that didn't have
quantum basis in it so
it will take a while
okay um right
right we are really short on time here
now with
i i understand that so we won't get
those things in immediately
um
why don't i hear when people study like
you know the d-wave
spin glass computery thing why haven't
i mean what what is the coefficient of
this
extra sort of commutator term what's it
called
michael
something that's the coherence i would
assume but it doesn't have a standard
name i mean it's not like
no i mean it's like that like the you
know
but i mean it is so you're saying it's a
single scalar thing
that determines essentially the
progressive diagonalization of the
density matrix
yeah more or less it's like happens
exponentially
this is a good question i'm
i don't think so i think you can
construct models
where it happens algebraically
okay but i don't know why i mean
sudden entanglement deaths and all the
things so it can
even happen and find a time to zero it
doesn't have to happen exponentially
okay but this doesn't sound like a
completely determined algebraic form
if if you can have all these different
cases no it's a differential equation
i understand that i understand that but
it's got but you described it as a bunch
of double commutators
not something where there's an arbitrary
function in there anyway no no no
o dot equal a double comma data you have
no idea what's the solution of this
differential equation
if you have random gunk in the
commutator yes
some operator which you is undefined
okay so we've got an
undefined operator that represents the
environment which is
you know has some master equation e type
thing yes yeah okay okay this is
unsurprising
right yes if i'd known about this in the
70s i would have ignored it on the
grounds of just
obviously something like that has to be
true but the question is what's the form
of that operator
and this is what i think kraus's
contribution is that there's
that's not too much choice okay that's
interesting
huh i wonder jonathan do you know about
this stuff
uh so i know about the about the
semi-group formalism which i think is
the way that it's described
mathematically i don't really understand
the physics but the
uh yeah i know about limb ludians in the
sense that they are just
sort of one parameter families of
quantum channels i think
so so to what extent is there a
conceptual link between this and kind of
like the canonical ensemble
in statistical mechanics where you say
sort of everything has to have that
distribution
except it doesn't in reality it it it is
the
equation that describes the evolution of
the canonical example uh
example well i understand but but but so
right okay okay so i understand how that
works in classical statistical mechanics
and the answer is that it's a big mess
right if you make certain assumptions
about two-body interactions and this and
that and the other you get some
particular hierarchy of equations
but you really don't know yeah right
the bbgky hierarchy and all that kind of
stuff
the but but that isn't very determined
the form is determined but the details
you know if you have something which has
only six body interactions or something
you can get all kinds of weird stuff
going on
okay so that that that's about that yeah
okay fine let's
where where i suspect all of those
parameters are unknown basically
but there's probably some way of doing
something that is
like the bgky hierarchy or like the
operator product expansion
that identifies what class of terms can
occur
okay let me put something in the chat
and
go to equation 49
on page 20.
okay then we're going to get back from
our physics moment
and um uh
question 49 on page 20
uh page 20.
okay that's a very concrete one
you see kind of like that as the kinetic
term and then there's the double common
data that
decreases okay fine
well it's interesting that it's as
explicit as that
but i mean this is just some random
approximation
case yes yes yes there are certainly
higher order terms
yes and no there are higher order terms
for each concrete
model but the structure has no higher
order terms
like that go back to uh 42. so
so you're arguing that like the
potential in the schrodinger equation
that the form the potential may be
unknown
but the way that it appears in the
children exactly like
the x is is the approximation go back to
the equation for the two
or for the three is it it must have this
shape
and the soy
okay okay well that's interesting you
could if you have more then you get
superliminal
information and all other things
can this be done for the dirac equation
as well
don't know
always a test with these relativistic
things
um okay well that's interesting all
right
cool well that was a useful thing to
learn all right
let's come back to making decisions here
yeah sorry but just
on a formalistic level the point i was
making was that you know just like
quantum evolution basically takes you
know a state or an operator or something
and turns it into a
a one parameter family of states and
operators obeying some function
um we can do a similar thing for the
limb vladian right because
it's what you have is just a you know a
family of density matrices that are
determined by this one parameter
symmetry semi group and if you specify
the semi group then right
you're done i see so it wouldn't
actually
require any significant code
modification
okay at a mathematical level i get it i
mean it's like
let the world be described by a semi
group and everything that happens within
it
the world is not a stage it's a semi
group never mind i'm just
being silly but but i mean yeah right
okay mathematically i understand
the um
okay all right so let's let's um
so okay decision if we
if we say quantum discrete for
everything here
and we put it in experimental system
context
um seems okay to me
i mean unless people yeah it seems okay
it seems like it's been developed enough
that we can do that what do you mean by
experimental
context just put no no i didn't mean
experimental context i just mean
in the system context tagged as
experimental
[Music]
i mean my main concern here is about the
time we have to finish
because we are so close and and i'm
aware but i mean so
so all we're doing is we're adding the
word discrete
to each of these quantum things that's a
nuisance but it's something i think we
can do
and flowing that through and getting it
out and it is a paclet updatable thing
right um
yes it it can be made yes but
so what about the idea of the particular
repo so
no it's not going to work it's not going
to work
because it's undocumentable we don't
have a mechanism for documenting that
yet
i mean how would you do it and where
would you put the documentation will it
be in the
generic website documentation if so
where we don't have a mechanism for it
yet
right i mean it's just that the original
idea was to treat this as
somehow the first example of of the
packet report
yeah but the package repo isn't ready
right right
so i think you know it's like what are
we going to do we've either got to
go to build that out which we can't do
right
in the time available or we've got to
put this as an experimental set of
system functions which is where they're
going to go anyway in the end
right so why not just do that i think
the the other possibility that was
discussed was having it
be in the repo having it be in the
packet repository and then expose
everything through wfr
oh that's a big pain in the neck
right i think you've gotten to the point
where i think this is well
shaken down enough that you know having
it be
an ex you know a set of experimental
system functions is okay
so what jonathan just said it might be
not so bad that this would be due for
vayne and it works i think pretty well
yes but but i i agree but this is a
i agree but i think this is more off on
a prong
right it's like it's design we've been
shaking down this design for like four
years or something
right this is not like a just came off
the boat type design
and i also don't think i mean that the
wayne stuff is mostly
stuff that you know maybe you know is a
bit too specific for students
the difference is it's one of
independent one of is a set that belongs
together i feel like that's a big deal
well yes
right
look i think we should add the discrete
word to this and we should make it
experimental system functions
okay unless anybody violently objects to
that i think that's where we should go
with this
and i think it's useful for people to
you know to feel that there's a quantum
framework that is built in
so that they can expect that it will be
maintained
and uh you know if they write if they
put
things in their papers that are these
you know representations of quantum
circuits that'll go on working
so long as we think there isn't a
problem with that i say we go ahead and
do this
will there be a convenient input form
for typing in cats and parts
anybody want to comment on that what
means not that inconvenient
also quantum discrete state is set up so
that you know if you just give it a
vector it will it will
do the pros and cons for you
i mean i can can i take a branch head
and edit it
uh yes yes well
let me let me see that work wait wait a
second so if i say
um
okay and then what happens now i go in
here and i change that
to 55. yeah it works just fine and
evaluated and it comes back
okay good nice
all right but also i mean in most
practical cases i suspect you wouldn't
i mean unless you're kind of
manipulating bases and unless you're
explicitly carving your own bases
you shouldn't need to modify browsing
cats you should but by the way by the
way on the guide page it should mention
brian kett
right why wouldn't it
how would we describe them is it in
basic objects
yeah probably can can i dot a bomb as a
cat
guys i mean listen this is not fully
not part of this framework that they're
they're general symbols right
yeah this framework they just happen to
be used as a convenient representation
for bases in this framework
yes i understand
so i mean i think that we should say in
the guide page it's what we do on a
guide page
and we should also look at the
documentation for briar and ket and make
sure that it's not crazy
can be more complex like if i think on
angular momentum states
i could have say j l and s in the
in the bar let's try it
nice like it nice
okay but bra has no documentation page
so it
should probably well i don't know but
the circle times doesn't have a
documentation page either
but this one
actually that's an interesting point
that this but circuit times doesn't take
no yeah it does actually yeah so bra
should have a documentation page
huh okay so it should have one like
circle times
does that make sense to people simply
just
did you understand people yeah
right now are notational devices for us
not not
semantic i understand so what should we
say in the guide page
basic notation or something
underlying notation for quantum states
what should we say
so right now we are using it i think
jonathan in terms of for the
basis vectors right rather than the j
exactly right so so a quantum discrete
state is just an association that maps
spaces vectors onto amplitudes and then
the basis vectors by default are
formatted with with cats
okay well so what should we say in the
guide page
so yeah i mean symbolic notation for
quantum
uh basis
state something like that
your quantum basis names
yeah okay symbolic notation for names
of quantum basis states is that right
it still feels a little weird with
putting this in the guide i mean like we
don't have
we don't have links off to like circle
times and things in the theorem proving
guide page
maybe we should but that seems we
probably should
okay should we have circle times on this
guide page as well
i think that's a that's a gender item
okay
actually i've got an idea let's put in
this thing
let's put something that says um
quantum notation
and then put this here
okay so then okay let's look at the
agenda
um okay
all right design
so these are two relatively minor points
but there are some places in which sql
times
is used and i think we should use the
directly tensor product
how is tensor product displayed
exactly in the same way with the circle
times
is it its own circle times that has a
built-in meaning
yes so you can you can actually use it
with arrays and
so if i if i look at tensor product
didn't we have it doesn't it have its
own glyph it does
that's the product has this uh it sounds
i mean it looks very similar i think
it's
fine i see okay
and this is operational so with symbolic
objects it will stay
nice if you actually gave an example it
used to circle times here
i see it's thin output but yes it can be
done an input too
so i mean if i take this then what
you're saying is
what is the notation what's it called
it's
escape the star
yeah what is
wow that's pretty cool actually well yes
i would think we should use this
but but but but but it's here it's
standing for quantum tensor product
isn't
takes it list of quantum elements and
then it returns
then the notational branch and cuts
right so so that that thing on the
left-hand side of the association is a
circle times
for the same reason that the brass and
kets are brows and cats right that
they're just names
[Music]
i see so so it doesn't actually have a
semantic meaning as a tensor product
that circle times doesn't uh but
obviously quantum intensive product does
and we discussed early on potentially
kind of overriding
tensor products so that if you if you
give it a collection of quantum objects
it will be a
constant product i think this seems a
bit dangerous i mean
you know using circle times is purely
notational
okay i mean i i don't know can we make
it actually work
the bras and cats don't mean anything
and there's no operation
if i'm correct other than that they're
used only for naming
yeah right right there's nothing i can
do with them as such
the thing you can do they don't have
meaning unless they are in a quantum
discrete
state right if they're just
basis names then you can't do anything
with them which is what they are here
okay okay okay
all right so now we have a question i
have a question to what jonathan just
said
so you said bars and cats have only
meaning
in the basis but but every state
is a bra right right sure
okay good no no of course right so
every every qds can be interpreted as a
bra or a category yeah
okay that's good yeah the the the point
is that
um you in addition to just knowing the
amplitudes you want to know what the
individual basis elements are called
and the point is the the the default
naming convention is to use cats
okay so i think we should say symbolic
notation
i would just say for quantum states
and leave it at that and then say here
and the next line if that's the only
other thing we've got
um and by the way documentationally
we should actually have a picture of a
bra here
in other um something like
like this
okay so circle time and then the
corresponding thing for cat
and then say symbolic notation
for uh quantum tensor products
tensor
is there any other notation that we're
using
uh there is an angle bracket but
i'm not sure maybe i will change it in
the future
well what what is that for that's for
expectation values
uh it's to collect uh measurement
results so for example the first
measurement i get zero on the second
measurement i get one
and i collect together into an angle
bracket the reason i use it because i
cannot use less
somehow uh the categorical distribution
framework that i've been using
interpreted differently
we need to understand that okay so what
you're saying is when you get out a list
of results
what you want is a categorical
distribution with certain probabilities
for certain
categorical outcomes and how would you
like to represent that
in other words what were you trying to
do
uh-huh so uh what i'm trying to do is to
make a single category contains multiple
numbers
for example uh like two measurements
have one z and one so the issue is
well okay so we should ask the
statistics people how to do that
i understand because categorical
distribution is using lists to represent
something different
yes but you don't want to use angle
brackets here because because
the thing you're looking at is
you know specifically
uh
um
um you know i am about to run out of
time but but we really have to we'll
have to continue this because
because we you know we need to get this
in
look i think we made a decision it's
going to be quantum discrete star
it's going to be part experimental part
of the system context
um i don't think this is right with this
angle bracket thing but we need to
ask the people who did categorical
distribution how to do this
if there is a way um
that's a nasty problem stupid problem
with categorical distribution design
mistake i think
um
okay can somebody make sure to ask can
we deal with that please
yes okay all right i i'm going to have
to go
in a second here um
no use of undefined entertainment versus
mixing quantum
yeah this is very minor it just there
are some places in which i think which
the use of undefined sims no it seems
wrong i mean
we don't even have is there even a
symbol called undefined
yes it's used in in logics statements
and conditional expressions etc
so if if if the result is a boolean
and the fine seems okay but if it's a
number it
i think no definitely not what what is
this case
let's see so this is
this is measuring an entanglement but
like a particular entangled measure for
example concurrence is only defined for
a certain case so if we
input a different state that is uh
that's not proper then
it will return undefined okay so there
are two possibilities either it's
missing or it's a failure
object if it's if it represents a
if if it is simply something that could
otherwise be a one
something like that i think it should be
a missing with some tag
that says what what some whatever it is
i don't know what what the right tag is
but something about undefined
does that make sense yeah i think so
okay let's be practical here this is
going to take a little bit more time
because we've got to
you know why doesn't it stay univolated
that could be two i mean if there is an
error
let's generate a message
right now it doesn't generate a message
but it's good as well
if i have a quantum state of two
particles and i ask
if the third and the fourth are
entangled i don't expect
undefined or flavor of it i expect to do
nothing
we could do that too sounds reasonable
to me
by the way i don't know what our
convention is for whether we have this
on the right-hand side of the left-hand
side
we should look for that i'm not sure
which what we've done in other places
um okay i think rockets are on the right
hand side
okay all right
fine we're not going to bracket the
bracket
i think we can get away with not
bracketing the bracket
um by the way sorry very mundane
question uh do we have error messages
yes yes not complete but but yes some
functions do have
okay good
distribution thing is there a reason why
we moved away from using empirical
distribution
um yeah so
um i think the reason was it's
hard to use when i want to do like
multiple
qubit measurement and something like
that
and in in quantum computer usually we
don't really care about
uh the average or things like that only
like
individual probabilities
yeah by the way on the guide page we
should list categorical distribution
somewhere
and other things that are used and
that's the point of guide pages
right there's nothing else that's
entrained into this
um okay listen practical thing i have to
go to this other meeting we need to
continue this at some point here
um i see there's a gap on my calendar
at in oh gosh how many hours is it
uh two and a half hours um so if
anybody's available to continue it then
i'd be happy to do it then um
yeah i don't think i can
hey i won't be able to either i have
another
okay well then then we'll get emma to
set something else up in the next
couple of days okay we need to continue
this
and finally get this to completion um
but why don't you go ahead and go you
know start making the change to quantum
discrete
and so on and i think that will get us
really close but we're still going to
have to review the documentation for
things and so on
make sense yep okay
okay and i will commit these changes
back to the system
um all right this is very good guys
i mean it's just uh it's been a long
road
let's um and i look forward to really
digging into tofix documentation stuff
um all right
well you you guys can keep going i i'm
i'm just i just have to go so i don't
know how you want to do this but
um okay i don't think we
okay all right see you guys soon okay
thanks okay